Bob: Oh god you're not the captain, you're just Jack!
Jack: Yup
Bob: Alright, are you the captain? Are you back captain? McCaptain Pants
Mark: Is that Ekka? No...
Bob: Where's our captain?!
Mark: Ekka?
Bob: Who's our fucking captain?! *Wade laughs*
Bob: Motherfucker drive the boat. Mark: There he is. There he is.
Mark: He's over there. He's over there.
Jack: He died.
Mark: No, he- he's down there.
Bob: He'll come back.
Bob: We're driving full speed at the fucking- uh - the  island!
Bob: All right, he's turning us.
Wade: Alrighty- die-ty, die-ty, die-ty...
Jack:Die-ty, Die-ty Die-ty Die. We once were on a pirate ship...
Mark: Oouu, hello.
Wade: Go left.
*Jack laughs*
Jack: The Dr-D was destroyed!
Mark:Yeah
Mark: You got a long ways off. Bob: Wait. wait I got one
Bob: I guess the doctor...wasn't in today.
Wade: YEAHHH
*Mark clapping*
Mark: You should be captain with jokes like that. That's great!
Bob: Yeah, with jokes like that, how am I not driving this boat?
Jack: With jokes like that, who even needs a ship?!
Jack: Okay, I'm coming in with the supplies. OH, right cannons, right cannons, right cannons!
Wade: Okay, I got the sail.
Mark: *mumbles* Yea.
Wade: Oh gods, right cannons!
Mark: Duckfoot time!
Jack: OH JESUS OW FUCK
Jack: Ahhh I'm hurt guys; I'm dead!
*Mark makes an unintelligible noise*
Bob: Did those guys pass already?
Mark: Yeah they went all the way around.
Jack: And they hurt us a lot...
Bob: Where the fuck are all these holes?
Wade: I'm thirty- OH! All the holes are in the back!
Bob: I'M PUMPING OH PUMP PUMP PUMP YEAH!
Mark: How can I not be hitting these guys?
Mark:This seems like exactly
Bob: I'll get the holes!
Mark: where I should be hitting.
Wade: There's two of the holes
Bob: There's the last one... I got it.
Jack: I like how it says "all pumps active" when we have one.
Bob: ALL of our one pump is acti--
Jack: OH JESUS!
Bob: OH GOD, JEEZ!
Wade: AhHhHHhhhHHHHh!
Jack: Left side!
Jack: LEFT SIDE! Get your Duckfoots men!
Wade: Captaaaainn!
Mark: I got my duckfoot!! Duckfoot time!
Jack: Get your duckfoots!
Bob: I got one I got one I got one!
Mark: Oh... It needs reloading, apparently.
Everyone: *pained noises*
Mark: *quietly* Ah I'm gonna fuck ya up.
Bob: Use the swivel guns USE THE SWIVEL GUNS
Jack: What was I killed by...? A PISTOL?!
Mark: Agh.
Mark: I'm gonna repair... somethin'.
Bob: *feared hooting*
Bob: Keep pumping, Keep pumping!
Bob: I got a pump!
Jack: I'm dead. I'm dead.
Mark: Ow, I've been hit, guys.
Wade: I'll be back in three seconds, dont you worry!
Mark: UGH the mother fucker went down!
Bob: Ahh the mother fucking ship was mother fucking-- *inaudible*
Wade: I'm BACK!
Mark: The mother fucker went down.
Jack: Where are we headin' lads?
Mark: I don't know.
Bob: Let's go back to the battle!
Mark: Let's fuck 'em up!
Mark: AND their mothers!
Bob: Let's go pir- pirate on them!
Bob: Let's get the pirates!
Bob: We're totally kicking ass!
Wade: I saw some pirate-on-pirate action with them.
Bob: If you push-if you push 'Q' you can see how far ahead we are.
Mark: Alright. I'll-
Mark: I'll be back guys, I gotta, I gotta go to the bathroom, okay? I'll be back.
Wade: *laughs*
Jack: It's okay, we'll take over your job.
Bob: Oh, honestly we're like tied with the top guys on the entire rest of our team.
Wade: I'm not, I'm not tied with anyone good.
Bob: Yeah, I'm excluding you. We're on a shitty boat so our scores are getting dragged down
but we're, we're tied with all the swag bros.
Jack: Ohhhhhh I didn't even realize that. Where, like Bodango Montoya only has 900 points.
Bob: Like a scrub.
Wade: Yeah, I've got like 3 points..
Bob: If you've got a most 900 points then you suck at everything
Wade: I'VE GOT 3 POINTS
Bob: Well that's inaccurate,
Bob: but you do have a hilariously low amount of points.
Jack: You have 720 you fuck, YA FUCK.
Bob: ALSO I CAN'T READ NUMBERS SO THANKS.
Jack: ALSO I DON'T READ NUMBERS SO QUICK.
Mark: I'm back! What did I miss?
Jack: We all died and won at the same time.
Bob: Mark, you lost! Yaaay!!!
Mark: What? Yaaaay!!!
Mark: Did that really happen or are you guys just goofing with me?
Bob: Nothing happened.
Mark: Oh, okay
Wade: Wait, which one are we hitting?!
Bob: The one to the right- oh, the one that's close! Right side cannons! Right, right side cannons!
Jack: I'm ready!
Mark: Alright, loading powder!
Jack: Ahhh, come on! A little closer! Ugh, don't turn ya fuck!
Wade: It's okay if they turn, hit their sails!
Jack: Captain, can you fucking turn?!
Jack: I really should be actually talking in voice chat.
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: It's F, hit F.
Bob: Man, if only we could talk directly to our team mates and coordinate.
Jack: TURN, CAPTAIN! TURN!
Mark: I'm gonna fire!
Bob: I'm trying to pick off their captain with my swivel gun.
Mark in the back: Hurrrrr-
Mark: -booski.
*Everybody shouting*
Mark: Where's the hole? Where's the hole?
Bob: I totally forgot they had cannons too, it's right by my dead body
*Mark laughing*
Jack in the background: Hey I hit him!
Bob: I was just standing just there like "man this is fun to shoot cannons at people-
-they don't shoot back, it's cool"
Bob: Captain don't battle like this, we're losing! We're at a bad spot!
Mark: No no, we're good guys. We're good, we're good, what're you talking about, we're good.
Jack: Okay, so health beverage is good- Somebody has their head through the floor!
Bob: Right side canons, load load load!
Mark: I got them, I'm going for it.
*Mark humming*
Mark: Boom!
Bob: Oh god, oh-
*Mark and Wade shouting*
Mark: Awww.
Jack: Get them?
Mark: I don't know, someone hit them.
Wade in the background: I killed this man!
Mark, laughing: "I killed a man!"
Mark: *pirate accent* They're- they're on both sides of us captain!
Mark: We seem to be in a bit of a pickle!
Jack, laughing: "Bit of a pickle!"
Bob: We seem to be in the worst possible situation--
Bob: Oh God we need so many supplies right now.
Mark: *normal voice* I got it guys.
Jack: Are we sinking?
Mark: Dude are you even- are you even remotely trying to say that I don't know exactly what I'm doing here?
Jack: I, uh--
Mark: Woah there's somebody floating in the ceiling here.
Mark: That's not- that's not a good sign.
Bob: Alright I brought supplies to the left side.
Mark: Okay.
Mark: Alright, I'm loading up. Loading up, loading up.
Bob: C'mon.
Mark: Pushing it.
Bob: Yes, that was a direct hit, yes!
Mark: Alright, I'm gonna see if I can hit it with this one.
Jack: Yeah I got them as well! Nice.
Bob: Good shit, boys.
Jack: Dude, we're fucking awesome, at this!
Bob: Boys! [pronounced buoy]
Jack: Yeah boys!
Mark: Yeah BooOoOoys.
Bob: Boyoyoyo-boys!
*Mark imitates Bob*
Mark: That's the sound of the mother fucker! Buu-yoyoyoyoy!
*Bob and Jack laughing*
Bob: It's the mother fuckers war cry. Boy-yuyuyuyuyoy!
*Jack joins in on boy-yoyoy*
Mark: *whispering* Fuck your mother--
Mark: *normally* Uh oh.
Mark: Ah, that--
Bob: *shouting* Oh god we're getting rammed!
*Everyone screaming*
Mark: Get footed!
Jack: Dr. Disappointment does not disappoint this day.
Bob: Get ready to fight.
*Jack makes a 'woo' noise*
Bob: Use your guns, use your swords.
Mark: They're on board?
Mark: More like they're on dead!
Bob: Yeah, they're on board.
Bob: They're on board in the back.
Mark: Hang on, wait. This guy- this guy is scary.
Mark: Ah, Duck-foot time!
*Firing gun*
Bob: Oh God.
Mark: How the hell did he not die?
Jack: *panicked* Oh God, Oh God, I'm here, I'm here!
Bob: Fix the holes, fix the holes!
Mark: Where's the holes-- There's the holes.
Random NPC in-game: There's a hole!
Mark: *mocking* There's a hole!
Bob: Get- get on the canons, get on the canons, retaliate!
*Everyone but Jack makes a weird noise*
Jack: Who's repairing sails?
Mark: I'm getting the sails!
Mark: *yelling* I got them I'm going for it!
Mark, struggling: Ah shit.
Wade in the back: I'm trying to learn where the pump is.
Mark: Guys--
Jack: They're right in the middle.
Bob: They're in the middle of the ship, man.
Jack: It's just a little handle.
Mark: I'll go get the sails, guys.
Mark: I'll go get these.
Bob: Have you really not known were the pump was this whole time, Wade?
Wade: Yep.
Bob: When everyone else was like totally on board with how it worked nd what the point was?
Mark, sheepishly: Yeah guys, everyone else was on board with it.
Mark, trying his best: Everyone knew, Wade, you idiot!
Wade: I- I- yeah, thank you for rubbing it in.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: I just wanted to make sure everyone knew that you didn't know about that thing-
Bob: -that everyone had known.
Mark, falling into the water: I fell, guys.
Mark: Guys, don't leave me, please.
Mark: Please.
Bob, laughing: Mark, you are so gone.
Mark: Guys, guys, please.
*Bob laughing*
*Jack laughing*
Mark: Guys don't worry, I'm gonna board their ship.
Jack: You fucking better.
Mark: I got it. Don't worry, I got it- they don't suspect a thing.
Mark: They also--
Jack: They might suspect something.
Mark: Ah, they left me behind, guys.
Bob: Uh, are we shooting off the right?
Bob: Oh, theyre flanking us, they're behind us right now.
Mark: Yeah, they're behind us.
Jack: *quietly* Shit.
Mark: I'm trying to go for this other ship.
Mark: Hang on. Wait. Might have something here.
Wade: That's a pirate ship you're shooting at!
Bob: No, behind us to the right, Wade, it's an enemy ship.
Mark: Okay alright, couldn't board them, that didn't work.
Wade: I know that, but people were still shooting at the pirate ship!
Mark: Alright, guys, I'm--
Bob: Left side canons, left side canons.
Mark: I'm in the ocean! Still... Didn't get on either ships.
Bob: It's alright mark,
Bob: just.. Fire to the left side canons, it'll be fine.
Mark: Me? I'm in the ocean.
Jack, firing canon: Boosh!
Bob: It's fine, it's fine.
Jack: Oh nice!
Bob: Oh shit snacks!
Jack: Nice hit.
Mark, still in the ocean: Good job guys!
Mark: I feel- I feel apart-- I'm dead, but I feel apart of this.
Mark: I feel like I'm participating.
Bob: We're gonna fucking run out of supplies.
Wade: NOO!
Wade: NOO, I died at the canon!
Mark: I didn't know that was possible.
Bob: Oh no we're ramming! I'm fixing, I'm fixing, I'm fixing.
Wade: Yeah, we got more holes.
Mark: Repairing.
Mark: Repair-- Aw I got- WOAH!
*Everyone yelling in shock*
Mark and Bob: Oh woah!
*Jack laughing*
Jack: Dude that was awesome!
Bob: Jesus Christ!
Jack: Oh no, ow!
Mark Oh no- I'm repairing something.
Bob: *hooting noises*
Jack: I'm dead.
Mark: Repairrring!
*Bob and Mark hooting in a shouting manner*
Bob: I'm dead.
Mark: Oh no. I think we died, guys.
*Wade makes a confused noise*
Bob: We can do it mark, bring it back!
Jack: That was fucking awesome.
Mark: Alright, I'm uh- I'mma go for them.
Mark: I'm going for them.
Bob: Wait, is our ship dead?
Mark: Yeah, ships dead, ships dead.
Bob: Okay yeah, our ship died. *laughing*
*Bob laughing*
Jack: Yeah, we super died.
Bob: Respawn into normal conditions with the ship just floating.
Jack: This game is the fucking best.
Bob: This is so good.
Mark: I know, I love this.
Bob: I can barely see whats happening, and it's fucking intense.
Mark: Wait-- I'm on our ally's pirate ship, guys. I dunno what happened.
*Mark and bob laughing*
Mark: I'm on the wrong ship, but uh..
Wade: How are you always at the wrong ship?
(general laughter)
Mark: I dunno...
Mark: I dunno how I got here, I guess I'm part of their crew now.
Mark: I'm just on their team now, so I'm just gonna...
Mark: Do my best here.
*Bob and Wade laughing*
Mark: 'Kay, never mind guys, I was the only one on their ship that got a canon ball to the face.
*Bob  and Jack laughing*
Bob: So off the bow, off the front, to the left end to the right are enemies, the middle is H.M.S Swag.
*Delayed cheering that they won while Mark laughs*
Bob: Time limit reached, just like in real piracy!
Mark: I did it guys!
Wade: I had two good hits--
(Everyone bursts into laughter)
Jack: Cannon fodder.
*Bob and Mark laughing*
Wade: I got cannon-ball'd.
Jack: Just from firing canons, we're killing everything.
Bob: Oh, we might have to try British.
Mark: Oh, I just clicked pirates.
Wade: I'm on pirates.
Bob: It's 8 to 12 British vs. Pirates right now.
Jack: Uh oh.
Bob: You guys can switch teams once you've selected.
Mark: Oh yeah? How?"
Bob: If you hit Esc, I think switching is a menu option?
Jack: I can only pick British.
Mark: Yeah, I'm going British.
Bob: We all- we can--
Bob: We can all switch to British I think.
Wade: Alright, I'm on British.
Mark: I'm on British.
Wade: Which one? Join the Poop or the-- oh..
Jack: *Laughing* Yeah you read it out loud then.
*Bob bursting into laughter*
*Bob still laughing*
Jack: Poop! Poop! Join Poop!
Bob: Lets join Poop.
Mark: *Tiny giggle*
Mark: Aw its full guys, its full guys. It's full.
Jack: Uhh Dr-D?
Mark: Yeah? You guys are so nice.
Jack: Aw fuck.
Bob: It's just the four of us?
Mark: Hell yeah! *Bob laughing*
Wade: No!!!
Mark: Yes!
Wade: No! Mark: Yes I'm okay with this.
Jack: Go Poop! Go Poop again!
Mark: What? No! I can't get in Poop.
Jack: Oh fuck.
Bob: Try Poop now! No, there's two spots on Poop.
Bob: Join Poop.
Mark: I- It's full!
Mark: There's one spot left for Poop.
*Various shouts for Mark to join Poop*
Mark: I don't even see Poop!
Mark: No, Poop is full! *Shouting continues*
Wade: Poop! Poop! Poop!
Mark: Oh wait, it's Harbringer now.
*Bob laughing*
Jack: Oh yeah, now I can't-
Jack: Oh yeah! Oh there we go!
Bob: We're all here! We're all here. Just-
Mark: Alright whatever.
Mark: Alright. We're all here, guys. We're all here. It's all good.
Bob: *while laughing* Just fuckin spawn in.
*Mark laughing*
Jack: Oh yeah. Spawn.
Bob: Oh my God. Geez.
Bob: You can change your side weapons? Oh fuck.
Mark: Yeah. Bob: I didn't know that!
Mark: You didn't know that? Jack: Yeah, Dude! The Duckfoot is king!
Mark: *burps* I got a bomb.
Game Character: Cannon ready!
*Laughter and various mocking of the game*
*More mocking*
Jack (In mocking voice): Smashing!
Bob: I'm getting the matchlock revolver.
Mark (still mocking): Guys look out! I threw a bomb.
Wade: I already took care of this one!
Bob: Hey! We're on a big boat.
Bob: No we're not. We're on a little boat.
Bob: We're on a shi- Woah! Woah! Wade: Which one are you?
Mark (still mocking): Sorry that was my bomb.
Bob: Cannons!
Mark (still mocking): Mmmm. Right side cannons ahoy-
Mark (still mocking): Too late. Mmm. Couldn't hit 'em. Mmmmm.
Bob: Oh! Sweet Jesus.
Bob: Oh God.
Mark (still mocking): Did it too late.
Wade: Command the ship.
Mark (still mocking): Ahhhh. We seem to be hit.
Mark (sounds constipated): Mmmm.
Bob: We have no holes... We need pumping! We need pumping!
Mark (still mocking): Yes, I don't know where the holes are...
Jack: Dead. Wade: And dead...
Bob: Goddamn island.
Mark (still constipated): Mmmm.
Mark: Where's the hole?
Mark (still mocking): Mmmm. Hole repaired!
Bob: We were ramming the pirate ship. I get it.
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: Fixing the- Oh there's pirates. Bob: Goddamnit! Fuck!
Bob: Switching weapons is so Goddamn janky!
Wade: Hey! There are pirates... on the pirate ship.
Bob: Wade, did you shoot at them? Mark: I'm going to throw a bomb!
Mark: Here we go! I think...
Wade: There ya go, Bob!
Jack: Why do I have tea?!
Bob: That's your heal drink.
Jack: Aw fuck.
Mark (still mocking): They have such minuscule dicks.
Bob: Oh I just threw a grenade. Look out. Jack: Get him!
Jack: Don't go in there! Don't go in there!
Jack: Oh God there's so many of them! There's three of them in there!
Mark (still mocking): Ow, I got shot. Mmmm I'm going down.
Mark: I can't tell...
Mark: With this normal, like, mini shot...
Mark: I don't know if it's got an arch to it.
Jack: Yeah, it's really hard to judge.
Mark: Yeah... Jack: It has a very small arch to it.
Wade: Are they all behind us? Or.. what's going on here?
Bob: Yes, we were in a bad spot there.
Bob: They're all, like, behind us right now.
Mark: MMMMM... Jack: Are cannons all loaded? Yes.
Mark: Reloading... Bob: Right side. Right side.
Mark: Right side you say? Bob: Oh, well, I'm turning around.
Jack: Front right. Front right.
Mark: Front right?
Jack: It's an enemy.
Bob: I think it's going to be a right side, broad side when we catch up to them.
Jack: How is that not a fucking hit?
Jack: Are you serious.
Jack: OH! That guy just... teleported.
Mark: It that some pirates?
Jack: Sail hit!
Jack: Okay. Right side.
Mark: I'm coming in for the kill. Bob: Right side main.
Mark (still mocking): Aaaand
Mark: Uuhhh turn a little left please...
Mark: Almost got it. And going for it!
Mark: Mmmbooski
Jack: You got him!
Mark: Oh! I've been shot!
Bob: Ooohhh they're about to slam into us.
Wade: Oh what?! NO! Mark: That hurt... a lot.
Mark: I seem to be bleeding...
Wade: I killed one as I died. Bob: Even though I died.
Wade: We shot at the same time.
Bob: Kill those bitches!
Bob: Heal yourselves! Heal yourselves!
Jack: I don't have heals!
Mark: I have grenades... no heals.
Wade: I'm repairing the boat!
Mark: Gonna throw a bomb!
Bob: Oh my God. I'm gonna fire a cannon at a thing that's 3 inches away.
Jack: That was awesome. Bob: Jesus christ.
Jack: Ok, they're coming right at us.
Jack: They're coming right for us.
Jack: Oh no! Our captain was killed!
Bob: Left side cannon!
Mark: Hang on... I'm trying...
Bob: I'm gonna go get on the wheel.
Mark: AHH! Come on, fire!
Jack: Got 'em! Mark: Yes!
Mark: Got 'em also.
Game character: You need to fix those holes!
Mark and Jack (mocking): You need to fix those holes.
Jack: Okay... scary. Scary!
Jack: OW! Mark: That guy died!
Wade: Oh oh oh. Bob: Ah geez.
Mark: That guy died good!
Bob: Oh no! Jack: Christ!
Mark: I died!
Mark: I died real good, too, guys.
Wade: Who's on fire!?
*Mark laughs* Jack: Me!!
*Mark and Wade laugh* Bob: You gotta go in the water!
Bob: You gotta put yourself out!
*Jack sighs* Mark: Oh no. The whole place is on fire.
*Wade laughing* Jack: I fucking died in the water.
Jack: On fire. Bob: So fucked right now.
Jack: How did I die from on fire while I'm in the water.
Bob: They're on our ship!
Mark: They're on our ship?
Mark: How droll.
Jack: Oh Jesus. Bob: What the Hell?!
Bob: What the fuck!
Jack: Tyrone!
Mark: Throwing a grenade.
Bob: Horrible shit is happening.
Mark: Throwing!
Wade: Did you just throw a cannonball at them? Bob: Oh God!
Mark: I threw a grenade at them, you fool! Bob: Fix the holes!
Mark: Our Harbringer has been blown.
Jack: I spawned onto a fucking downed ship.
Mark: I am coming for you.
Bob: Get on their ship!
Jack: I can't get on!
Mark: Nope. I'm dead. Bob: There should be a way to climb up here.
Mark: Nope. Died.
Jack: Oh! There's a guy right here!
Bob: There's no fucking way to get up there! Jack: Oh no!
Mark: There's gotta be a way you get rope and throw it.
Mark: 'Cause there's like a grappling hook that's the rope thing.
Bob: Yeah it must be.
*Everyone sighs and groans*
Jack: Goddamnit! Mark: Alright...
Mark: Resupplying!
Jack: We have a terrible captain this time.
Bob: Our captain's an idiot.
Wade: He didn't want...
Wade: He wanted me to be captain, I mean, he doesn't want to be captain.
Jack: Yeah? Well, he should have thought about that before he became captain.
Jack: Oh we're getting fucked. Wade: Go captain, Bob.
Mark: We're not getting fucked persay...
Bob: Alright, I'm captaining.
Mark: We've got enemies behind those rocks.
Wade: There's a Jedi ship over there. They would be good.
Mark: Jedis you say...
Jack (in mocking accent): Jedis you say!
Jack: Everyone has to speak in British accents.
Jack: From now on, the entire rest of the episode.
Mark: That's all I've been doing!
Wade: I'll have a martini, shaken, not stirred. Jack: Smashing my good man.
Wade: Wait, that's just Sean Connery, not British.
Mark: That's Scottish. Sean Connery is from Scotland.
Bob: I'm gonna try and slip in towards our allies.
Bob: And then we'll engage with them... maybe.
Mark: What was the button to see where people were?
Jack: Q, my good man. Wade: Q
Mark: Mmmmmmm Q...
Jack: It's the one that looks like an O with a little tail. Bob: Indeed, sir.
Mark: OH! A fat man with a dick.
Bob: The captain removed me from the wheel?
Jack: Front right!
Bob: What?! The fuckin' captain just took over.
Jack: Fuck that guy.
Mark: There's gotta be a way to switch...
Bob: He was asking for someone else to be captain.
Mark: There's gotta be a way to really switch.
Mark: Uh oh that's-
Bob: He can relinquish his command, I know he can...
Jack: Yeah, but he shouldn't be able to get it back.
Bob: Well, I don't think he ever relinquished his command is the thing...
Jack: Ok, front right. Front right.
Mark: Got it!
Mark: Goin' for it.
Bob: Are we going to have our broadside coming up?
Mark: Depends on where he goes...
Mark: Maybe.
Jack: Who just died? Mark: Ow, I got dead.
Bob: Pump guy died, Mark died in the front.
Bob: Right cannons, right cannons, right cannons.
Jack: Kay, I'm getting ready.
Bob: Nope, we're not lined up. Mark: Alright, alright...
Mark: Okay, I'm gonna try and throw a bomb over there.
Bob and Jack: Left cannons, left cannons!
Mark: Throwin' a bomb!
Mark: Jumpin' like a goof
Jack: Okay, I hit him.
Jack: Oh yeah! Oh that's a lot of dams.
Bob: Oh my God. We just fucked on them so goodly.
Jack: Oh god, oh god...
Jack: No not the fuckin' grenade, you cock!
Mark: I like grenades.
Jack: There's a grenade, there's a grenade, there's a grenade!
*Wade shouts* Wade: Found it...
Mark: Ah, I killed somebody.
Jack: Watch out, man.
Wade: Jack was right... it was there...
Mark: "Booper, are you able to talk?" says Cody.
Jack: Umm, fuck you , Cody.
*Bob laughs*
Mark: Aaaand lining up a shot...
Mark: Indeed- OW!
Bob: Oh, God. I just got totally wrecked by a Goddamn cannon shot.
Mark: Ah but I hit him. That's what's good. Bob: Lots of holes.
Bob: Need the pumps. Jack: I need to repair sails, but the fuckin' hit boxes are weird.
Bob: Anyone on the pump? Do we have anyone on the pump?
Mark: I'm fixing holes.
Bob: I'm dead. We're so fucked.
Mark: Going for pump, going for the pump, going for the pump.
Jack: Oh there's a guy right here! Oh Jesus!
Mark: Oh, it's in use.
Bob: Pirate on the ship! Pirate on the ship!
Mark: Oh, we might be down...
Wade: There's no ship.
Jack: Oceanman just wasted four of us...
Mark: Oooohhh Oceanman...
Wade: Though, I'm still somehow pumping...
*Mark laughing*
Mark: Just pump into the bottom of the ocean...
Mark: "I'll get it guys! Don't worry!"
Mark: "I got this!"
Mark: I think the tactic here is, our captain's not ramming people...
Mark: And also not positioning us.
Bob: Our captain is generally just sucking at getting our guns on people.
Mark: That's also a thing.
Wade: I'm still pumping according to my screen
*Mark laughs*
Bob: We're about to get absolutely shrekt by the pirates.
Mark: You don't know that.
Bob: If you look at the tickets, you can see...
Mark: What? Nah, man. Come on...
Jack: We have 24 lives... Wade: We have 24, this is like golf.
Jack: They have 101.
Bob: It is like golf...
Mark: Guys, we can bring this back.
Bob: ...we all suck at it.
Bob: Would be how this is like golf.
Mark: Guys, come on.
Jack: Imma light you on fire, Wade.
Wade: Ah! Stop!
Bob: Mark are you hot? Hot damn?
Mark: Huh? What?
Bob: Do I need to call the folice or the fireman?
Mark: Ah, hmm.
Bob: The folice... the fake police.
Mark: Is that that Bruno Mars fellow?
Jack: Does Bruno Mars is gay?
*Wade laughs* Mark: Mmmm rumors say has come out.
Bob: Right side cannons.
Mark: Or dead ahead apparently.
Wade: We're rammin'!
Mark: Woah, huzzah.
Bob: Jesus Christ! Ahhh!!
Bob: Left side Cannons!
Mark: Splashed 'em!
Bob: Shit's all fucked!
Mark: I'm going to pow them!
Mark: Ow, been fucked.
Bob: No, how did that kill their captain?
Jack: There's two ships over there.
Bob: We need to fix the nose. We need to fix the nose and the holes.
Bob: Oh shit, fire!
Bob: Get buckets. Get buckets and put the fire out!
Mark: Oh boy...
Mark: Alright, I don't know where the buckets are.
Bob: Buckets are at the front right. We're good, we're good. We're good, I'm gonna pump.
Jack: Oh god, oh god...
Bob: OH NO! OH GEEZ!
Mark: Oh holy shit.
Jack: We are getting fucked. A lot of people just died.
Bob: Just fix the holes and pump!
Mark: I don't think...
Jack: Fixing the nose!
Bob: Fix everything!
Jack: We lose. We have no lives.
Wade: NOOOOOO Mark: It's okay.
Mark: We've done our best...
Jack: We won in spirit!
Mark: MMMmmmmm
[Awesome outro music]
*end of video*